[Music]
everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're going to be
going over a very important technique
that every chess player needs to know
and that is pins and skewers and a lot
of people know kind of what a pin is and
how to find you know easy pins and easy
skewers today we're gonna be going over
advanced skewers and advanced pins and
how to find them in their own game and
how to implement them into your own game
so first thing we're going to look at is
the is the pin and most people can tell
just by looking at it that if it's
White's move the best move for white is
going to be move rook to f1 and
basically what we're doing is we're
pinning the Queen down to the King and
black really doesn't have a lot of
options his best option is just going to
be to take this rook and after we
exchange why it's gonna have a pretty
easy in game black cannot move his Queen
because it's in needle to illegal move
on the flip side we will take a look at
a skewer and basically what a skewer is
is if the more powerful piece the King
is in the front basically we're going to
skewer the Queen away or skewer the King
away and capture the Queen so that
basically looks like rook to f1
attacking the king and the King's gonna
have to move and in return we can just
take the Queen so obviously as you can
see in these two examples what a pen and
a skewer are a lot of the times though
in your game your opponent's not gonna
baby feeds you the easiest pins and
skewers you're gonna have to find some
pins and skewers on your own and so in
the next couple examples we're gonna
take a look at some more advanced
concepts in this example you can
probably see that the best move here is
to simply move rook to a eight basically
making a skewer here where the king is
gonna have to move and the Queen will be
hanging and we can trade off our rook
for a queen which is very good for us
but let's go ahead and take a look at if
we change up pieces from the beginning
and instead of having our rook here we
have our queen so before we had our rook
here and our queen here and we just
switched them now if we move our Queens
to a a which a lot of beginners will do
once the King moves then the Queen can
capture but then black can immediately
recapture so what we need to do is we
need to find a more advanced skewer and
basically what this looks like is we
need to find a way to get this Queen
away from the square that it's on so
that we can skewer with a eight and what
that move is gonna look like is rook to
g8 basically you can see this skewer
right here where the Queen cannot move
because the King is behind it so the
Queen's going to either have to stay
here and get captured or capture this
piece now obviously a lot of people
would just say hey you're losing a rook
but once black captures this white rook
then Y can come into a a
check the king in sewer the black queen
so now when black moves is keen now
white can come in and capture the black
queen and now we have traded a rook for
the black queen so as you can see this
is a little more advanced than just your
normal skewer but these will come up a
lot more often where your opponent may
not see where you can kind of distract
them and then go in for the skewer that
you're looking for so we'll go ahead and
take another look at a different example
let's go ahead and take a look at this
example right here and take just a
minute what you think White's best move
hit move is here in this particular
situation you can pause it take a minute
look at and see what you think and
hopefully you came up with a lot of
beginners like the last example would be
completely fine we'll just bring in the
Queen to b8 and when the King moves then
just trading off Queens here but that's
not the best move here we have the best
move of rook to b3 which does two things
one that skewers the black Queen and
King but it forces black to come down
and cap Travie see if he does not
capture then we can just capture with
our rook on the next move so once black
captures now the white queen can come to
b8 and skewer both the king and the
queen basically leaving the black queen
hanging so it's these little advanced
moves finding the the skewer that can
really change your game up we'll look at
one more example of one of the easiest
ways that you can start to look for
different advance fewer plays in your
own game so let's go ahead and take a
look at one more let's go take a look at
our last example and the first thing you
need to notice in this example is that
black has a very big weakness and that
is along the a2 to the GA diagonal and
one of the good things that white has is
we have our light squared bishop that we
can anytime come to b3 and attack the
King on g8 so one of the things that
you'll see a lot of times players do is
try to let's say black tries to take
away this diagonal from white obviously
white cannot bring his Bishop to b3 or
then both bishops will be traded off and
Y will be losing its active Bishop and
blacks giving up his act his bishop it
was not very active black also feels
like this is a good spot because white
can't capture with his knight because
the queen is defending it and since this
is a great outpost for the knight at the
moment blocking this F pawn and
supporting porting this supporting this
area at any time he can jump in black a
lot of times a fool pretty safe well
black doesn't realize is white can
actually capture this Bishop on d5
without being recaptured if black were
to decide to capture this Bishop on d5
he would miss a very powerful pin with
Bishop to b3 so a lot of players miss
this in their own games they're always
looking for the obvious pin or the
obvious skewer and a lot of times they
don't realize that if they look just a
few moves ahead they can find an even
more powerful pin or a more powerful
skewer so in your own chess games always
be looking a few moves ahead and see if
you know if you capturing a piece if
your opponent recaptures can then you
set up a more powerful skewer or a more
powerful
so hopefully you guys enjoy the video
hopefully you can implement this in your
own game hopefully you guys learned a
lot if you haven't subscribed go ahead
and please subscribe I appreciate it and
I'll see you guys next video leave
comments let me know what y'all liked
about the video which I'll did it and
I'll see y'all next time thanks a lot